Monka W!
Easy!
So, da bin ich!
Ich bin echt gespannt!
Morgen Mittag kann ich mein neues Auto abholen!
Mal schauen, wie das so ist dann!
Ich meine, das ist ja immer noch was anderes, als da ein paar Mal um die Ecke mit zu fahren und es dann halt wirklich zu haben!
Ich bin echt mal gespannt, wie es mit dem Elektroauto so ist!
Äh, was mir... ich hab ein...
Ich hab's glaub ich sogar noch auf hier irgendwo!
Den da!
Ups!
Das da!
Als Form für Auto!
Den grün!
Oder den ozeangrün, was eher aussieht wie blau!
Ja, hat's!
Freunde, Musik ist ein bisschen laut!
Zu anstrengend!
Ich brauch was entspannenderes!
Haben wir nicht irgendwie hier Relaxing... was ist denn das?
Relaxing Nintendo? Irgendwas?
Ah, das da!
Ja, besser!
Ja, also!
Ja, das hat noch so schnell geklappt!
Ich hatte Glück, Game up! Danke für den Sub! Und hier, Silvercross auch, hab ich oben!
War noch, bevor ich das Headset dran hatte!
Ja, hat so schnell geklappt und zwar...
Ich hatte wirklich Glück, ich hab da einen Termin gemacht...
Zum Probefahren!
Hier bei mir in der Nähe!
Und...
Die meinten irgendwie, ja, also...
Sie haben welche bestellt!
Gucken wir doch mal, was von denen die bestellt sind!
Und noch nicht verkauft sind!
Was da am besten passt zu dem, was ich mir so vorstelle!
Und am Ende von der Probefahrt meinte er dann irgendwie so...
Ach ja, und hier das Probefahrauto...
Das stellen wir auch demnächst ins Internet!
Dann hab ich gemeint, ja dann stellts doch mal nicht demnächst ins Internet!
Sondern sag mir, was ihr für haben wollt!
Und ja, so am Ende hat es jetzt...
25.200 Euro gekostet!
Was wirklich in Ordnung ist!
Für zumindest im Anbetracht der Tatsache, was es normalerweise kostet!
Natürlich...
Wenn man sich überlegt, was man sich für 25.000 Euro schon für andere...
Hätte Autos kaufen kann, muss das sich jetzt im Endeffekt jeder selbst überlegen!
25.000 Euro ist schon mal eine Hausnummer!
Aber normalerweise kostet es ja noch mehr!
Also normalerweise, wobei das würde ich im Leben nicht ausgeben!
Ich gebe doch keine 41.000 Euro für so ein kleines Stadtauto aus!
Dann kann es ja noch so viel Elektro sein!
Und...
Naja, zumindest...
Ich hab mir so gedacht, wenn wir irgendwie unter 30.000 Euro kommen, denke ich drüber nach!
Es muss auf jeden Fall dieses Jahr sein!
Damit das mit der Prämie noch klappt!
Und jetzt habe ich am Endeffekt 25.200 Euro bezahlt!
Das ist okay!
Das hat auch nicht viele Kilometer gefahren!
Ich meine, es ist ein Vorführauto da für 4-5 Monate gewesen!
Und ich bin echt mal gespannt, wie es ist!
Ich habe mir das ganze Handbuch schon angeguckt von der Kiste!
Weil du hast ja im Vergleich zu meinem alten, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es hier noch offen habe!
Also, guck mal!
So sieht der neue von innen aus im Cockpit!
So sieht der neue aus im Cockpit!
Und so sah mein alter aus im Cockpit!
Haltet euch fest!
High-end!
Aber gut, mein altes Auto ist auch 20 Jahre alt!
Mal ganz davon aussehen, das da unten habe ich gar nicht!
Da ist bei mir einfach nix drin!
Ich habe nur ein Radio drin und den Rest des Zeugs habe ich da gar nicht!
Weißt du, ob man Chrome-Taps einzeln muten kann?
Also, beim Firefox kannst du hier oben klicken!
Ich glaube beim Chrome nicht!
Aber was ich mache, ich habe dieses Addon hier!
Den Volume-Master!
Also der hat nichts mit dem Coin-Master zu tun!
Da kannst du auch muten!
Und lauter machen, einzelne Taps!
Wobei man halt sagen muss, das geht nicht über die Windows-Lautstärke-Regelung, sondern über den Browser!
Das heißt, mehr als die maximale Lautstärke von Windows kannst du da auch nicht machen!
Weil dann übersteuert es halt im Endeffekt!
Geht das mit dem muten noch? Zeig es mal her!
Ach, hier kommt man!
Mute-Zeit, funktioniert noch!
Deswegen finde ich das Addon wirklich sehr praktisch!
Weil du gerade, wenn ich hier für den Streamer ein bisschen was einstellen muss, Musik, Lautstärke und so, ist das manchmal nicht genug, dass du es über den YouTube-Regler machst!
Weil der YouTube-Regler ja, der hier unten, der geht ja dank Tablet-Bedienung und allem, was die Seite unterstützt, mittlerweile nur in kleinen Schritten!
Wieso kein Tesla? Weil Teslas relativ groß sind und teuer!
Und ich weder 50k plus ausgeben will, noch ein großes Auto will!
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich bin froh, dass es so schnell geklappt hat! Und ich meine, der Vergleich...
Ja, das habe ich mir schon mal angeguckt, Beis!
Ich meine, der Vergleich ist schon wirklich offensichtlich, oder?
Das sieht halt aus wie ein Auto vor 20 Jahren!
Und das sieht halt halbwegs modern aus!
Und das ist mehr oder weniger auch genau das Setup, was ich habe, was man hier sieht!
Also, das hier nicht! Ich habe keine hier Spezial-Armlehnen mit Gedöns!
Aber hier vorne ist genau das gleiche!
Klimaanlage, Heizung, Lade, Lade-Ding mit USB-Anschlüssen!
Ja, das hier ist im Endeffekt die Gangschaltung!
Also, Parken, Rückwärts, Leerlauf, Drive, logischerweise! Fürs Fahren!
Und das hat halt den ganzen Krämpel hier drauf!
Tja, echt mal gespannt, wie das dann so ist!
Nichts, das da unten ist übrigens die Handbremse!
Die ist jetzt einfach nur so ein Knopf, den du hoch und runter machen kannst!
Das ist Lautstärke für Radio und Telefon! Und das hier ist Mode-Selection für den Fahrmodus!
Also, du kannst ja einstellen, dass das Ding ganz normal fährt!
Also sprich Gaspedal und Bremsen!
Dann kannst du einstellen, dass das Ding automatisch bremst, wenn du vom Gaspedal runter gehst!
Und dadurch ein bisschen die Batterie auflädt!
Das ist ganz praktisch! Da kannst du theoretisch quasi nur mit einem Pedal fahren!
Gut, manchmal musst du natürlich trotzdem bremsen, wenn dir die Oma vor das Auto rennt oder so!
Du kannst mit der Handbremse nicht mehr driften!
Das ist richtig! Das wird wahrscheinlich da weniger funktionieren!
Der macht den Parkmodus auch automatisch... Nee, der macht die Handbremse auch automatisch aus, sobald du Gas drückst!
Also, sobald du aufs Gaspedal drückst, macht er die Handbremse automatisch aus!
Dann wird das Auto geflasht! Das erste, was ich machen werde, ist ein Firmware-Update, ganz logisch!
Ich habe mich auch schon schlau gemacht, was CarPlay und alles angeht! Das Ding kann Wireless CarPlay!
Das heißt, diesen Navigator da drinnen werde ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht verwenden!
Sondern ich werde im Prinzip zu 90% übers Handy navigieren!
Einfach, weil das Display... Ich habe es ausprobiert! Das Display ist okay!
Das ist jetzt nicht super responsive! Das ist aber auch nicht...
Laggy as fuck!
Das ist okay! Das kann man bedienen, aber ich weiß nicht, was die Autohersteller machen, ehrlich gesagt!
Ich habe gehört, bei Tesla soll das viel geiler sein!
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die Autohersteller machen, aber diese ganzen eingebauten Entertainment- und Infosysteme, die es da gibt,
die sind alle immer mega laggy zu bedienen! Ich weiß nicht, warum!
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man nicht ein Touchscreen bauen könnte, mit flüssiger Bedienung!
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob die wirklich jeden Cent beim Chipsparen müssten, oder irgendwas einbauen, was 15 Jahre alt ist, oder so!
Oder ob da jetzt irgendwie ein 486er drin ist!
Nee, das ist nicht, weil ich irgendeinen Arm... Low-Power-Arm-Ding... Aber trotzdem!
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum die Touchscreens immer so kacke sind und die Bedienung von diesen Dingern immer so lahm ist!
In dem Fall, es geht! Also du kannst das... Ich weiß nicht, ob man hier ranzoomen kann...
Ja, du kannst das ohne Probleme bedienen, aber du merkst das gerade, wenn du swipes oder wenn du hier die Buttons drückst,
dass es teilweise... Du drückst und dauert halt eine halbe Sekunde!
Was halt... Was halt für ein Arsch ist! Und wo ich mir halt denke, wenn der Kram...
Also niemand wird das hier wahrscheinlich freiwillig bezahlen, aber geben wir mal...
Also die wollen das halt haben! Oder empfehlen das zumindest!
Und da für einen laggy Bildschirm... Ich meine...
Jedes... Sagen wir mal, jedes iPad ist schneller!
Und das ist mit Sicherheit billiger!
Und jedes halbwegs Mittelklasse Android-Handy ist deutlich, deutlich, deutlich schneller!
Also keine Ahnung! Keine Ahnung, was die da treiben! Aber okay!
Ja, ich bin wirklich mal sehr gespannt, wie es ist, dann Elektroauto zu fahren!
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die einzelnen Knöpfe machen, wenn ich ehrlich bin!
Ich weiß übrigens auch gar nicht, wie man hupt! Wie hupt man? Das braucht man für Frankfurt!
Für Frankfurt ist das wichtig!
Wie hupt man denn? Wahrscheinlich in die Mitte hauen, oder? Nee!
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man hier hupt!
Hab ich noch nicht gebraucht, bis jetzt! Wo hupt man denn hier?
Irgendein Knopf, oder in die... Nee, hier! Hier! Außen!
Hier außen drauf, wahrscheinlich!
Naja!
Ah, hier hast du die Freisprechanlage!
Naja, gut!
Alles klar!
Die Saulo gibt's nächste Woche!
Und mein Agila hat dann endlich ausgedient!
Der Grüne!
Den muss ich heute Abend noch ausräumen!
Hupe ist Touchscreen, dritte Menü eben!
Das wird mich echt nicht wundern!
Oder ich muss sagen, hey Fiat, hupt mal! Oder so!
Das Ding hat ja angeblich, laut Handpapier,
das Ding hat ja angeblich, laut Handbuch, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert,
das Ding hat ja angeblich Voice, Voice-Bedienung,
kannst du hier oben draufdrücken, oder kannst du ein Code-Wort angeben,
da kannst du dann sagen, hallo Fiat, mir ist kalt!
Und dann macht er die Heizung an!
Mal gucken, was es alles für Kommandos gibt!
Ich denke mal gerade in Kombination, ich hab mich ja da im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen schlau gemacht,
ich denke mal gerade in Kombination mit meinem iPhone
und Shortcuts und irgendwelchen CarPlay-Triggern
und eventuell dann WLAN-Triggern, so nach dem Motto,
wenn man heimisches WLAN entert oder wenn man sich beispielsweise,
wenn irgendein Message kommt und wenn CarPlay connectet,
kann ich mir zum Beispiel ansagen lassen, ob der Parkplatz vor dem Haus frei ist und solche Sachen.
Also da lässt sich auf jeden Fall mit CarPlay einiges machen,
was ein bisschen blöd ist,
dass CarPlay keinerlei Video-Output unterstützt.
Ich meine, ich verstehe es, warum CarPlay kein Video-Output unterstützt,
die wollen nicht, dass die Leute gegen den Baum fahren
und dann in den Nachrichten kommt, der Typ hat mit CarPlay gerade YouTube-Videos geguckt oder Pornhub.
Ist klar, warum die das nicht wollen.
Man kann da ein bisschen tricksen mit CarPlay,
du kannst anscheinend dein iPhone-Bildschirm mirron auf dieses Display
und dann halt alles ausführen, was du willst.
Wie gesagt, ich will keine Videos gucken während der Fahrt,
aber zum Beispiel für Kameras wäre das ganz cool, ja.
Also mal angenommen, ich würde mir eine Dashcam einbauen
und ich will die auf dem Display mir angucken.
Das ist halt kacke, weil das ist laggy as fuck,
wenn du es über Screen-Mirroring machst,
wenn du es über Airplay oder sowas casten könntest oder sowas,
was es ja nicht kann, dann wäre es wahrscheinlich deutlich schneller.
Das ist Wireless CarPlay.
Der Honda e hat für das Display ein HDMI-Eingang, ja, das ist gut.
Das ist gut, HDMI-Eingang.
Das ist Pogge, weiß ich.
Geht das da auch?
HDMI, Moment, was?
Sekunde.
Was?
HDMI?
Hat das auch, ich habe kein HDMI gesehen.
Was ist hier mit HDMI?
Hier steht überhaupt nichts von HDMI, das ist Chebat.
Das ist Massive Chebat, die Seite.
Nee, das ist der Honda e.
Nee, das hat kein HDMI, das hätte ich gesehen.
Aber ein HDMI wäre wirklich praktisch.
HDMI wäre wirklich Pogge.
Da könnte man einfach die Dashcam irgendwie da einstecken.
Ich sage mal so, normalerweise würde ich mir sowas gar nicht
als Auto machen mit meinem alten Auto,
weil wenn das kaputt ist, ist es egal, aber das neue ist halt ein bisschen teurer.
Ja, also wie gesagt, hat so schnell geklappt.
Lässt du dir eine Wallbox installieren? Ja, mache ich.
Wobei ich schon wieder kommen sehe, dass die Elektriker da komische,
komische Dinger machen und nicht versuchen zu Chebaten.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was los ist mit Handwerkern.
Es geht jetzt wirklich, muss ich wirklich sagen, nicht,
auch wenn es sich sehr pauschal anhört, aber ich wurde in letzter Zeit öfters versucht
zu Chebaten von Handwerkern, von Werkstätten, von allem Möglichen,
die sich dann immer irgendwelche Dinge ausdecken,
warum sie irgendwas, was ich will, nicht machen können.
Ich habe beim Elektriker angerufen und gesagt,
hier, ich würde gerne eine Wallbox installieren lassen.
Und da meinten die, oh, das ist ja in nächster Zeit ganz furchtbar schlecht,
weil wir haben nur einen, der das machen kann,
und der ist jetzt auf der Baustelle und danach ist er im Urlaub.
Aber vielleicht kann er mal gucken, da können wir uns schon was aussuchen.
Und da meinte ich, ne, ne, wir müssen uns nichts aussuchen.
Ich kaufe eine Wallbox und die baut die Wallbox ein.
Wir müssen uns da nichts aussuchen.
Ich weiß genau, welches ich haben will.
Ja, aber da musste er vorher mal kommen und gucken, ob das auch geht,
wo ich mir so denke, alter, hört auf mich die ganze Zeit zu verarschen.
Das fuckt mich mega ab.
Alle wollen sich verarschen und wollen dir irgendwas ablabern an mehr Kohle.
Ich weiß genau schon, was ich mir für eine Wallbox kaufe.
Und das Ding hat vier Kabel.
Da musste der Elektriker das verlängern vom Verteilerkasten,
vielleicht ein Zwischenverteiler-Ding in den Keller machen
und dann das Kabel anschließen.
Fertig.
Das sind nackte Kabel mit ADN-Hülsen drauf.
Der muss da, also, es ist nicht so, als müsste der sich jetzt super, super krasses Zeug,
das kann jeder, bin ich bezüglich, das kann jeder Elektriker machen.
Was ich mir kaufen will, ist folgende.
Wie heißt das denn?
ADAC Wallbox-Test.
Nicht, dass ich allein darauf so viel geben würde, wenn ich nicht nur andere Tests gucke,
aber ich weiß, die war relativ, das Ding, die stand dabei.
Das Teil.
Das da.
Mein Hausanschluss macht das.
Wenn mein Hausanschluss die Leistung nicht trägt,
dann könnte er auch keine andere Wallbox einbauen.
Und es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das hier super krasser Shit.
Das Ding.
Und warum?
Weil es hat zwei Gründe, warum ich mir die kaufen will.
Erstens, weil die relativ günstig ist,
weil die in den meisten Reviews und Tests wirklich gut abgeschlossen hat.
Nachteil ist, man findet im Internet ein paar Benutzerberichte,
die sagen, nach 1, 2 Jahren ist ihnen das Ding durchgeschmort.
Du wirst da wahrscheinlich zu allen Sachen finden
und wer weiß auch, was die Leute damit treiben.
Also, hat wirklich gute Reviews, ist relativ günstig
und was mir persönlich gut gefällt, ist die Smartphone-Integration.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ihr kennt mich, ihr kennt mich.
Weniger die Smartphone-Integration,
was ich persönlich äußerst ansprechend finde, ist,
dass die, nicht Home Assistant, die haben
und das machen wenige Hersteller.
Ihr wisst, wie es ist.
Das hört sich jetzt fast an wie das Video vom Assi-Tony.
Ich erzähl nix, oder?
Was hat er gesagt?
Ihr wisst, wie es ist.
Also Leute, ihr wisst, wie es ist.
Das machen wenig Hersteller.
Die haben eine MQTT- und HTTP-API.
Standardmäßig drinnen.
Zeigt mir mal einen Hersteller, der sein Gerät nicht verrammelt bis sonst was
und offiziell offene APIs anbietet.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Das macht keiner.
Die haben sogar API-Docs auf GitHub.
Das muss man sich mal überlegen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, Cloud-API braucht man nicht.
Aber du kannst, wie gesagt, eigene MQTT-Server hier zum Beispiel.
Hier, da war's.
Eigene MQTT-Server.
Ab Firmenversion ist es möglich,
einen eigenen MQTT-Server zusätzlich zur Go-E-Cloud zu...
Ja, die Go-E-Cloud werde ich eh nicht verwenden.
Das ist richtig nice.
Und dementsprechend gibt es dafür selbstverständlich schon...
Home Assistant Integrations.
Die dann zum Beispiel so aussehen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es da zwei verschiedene gibt, aber...
Ja, die sehen dann so aus.
Guck, da hast du direkt im Home Assistant...
Hast du dann deinen Charger.
Du kannst auswählen, an, aus.
Du kannst das ganze limitieren, wenn du den Akku nicht voll machen willst.
Oder wenn du sagst, hey, ich will gleich losfahren, ich mache jetzt aus.
Oder was auch immer.
Weil die Fiat-Firmware ist ja ein bisschen fail, was das angeht.
Also mein neues Auto ist nicht in der Lage,
über die App das Laden an und aus zu schalten.
Was auch relativ firnverbrannt ist.
Du kannst bloß sagen, maximal 80% laden oder so.
Aber du kannst nicht sagen, jetzt laden an und aus.
Dann mache ich es halt über die Ballbox.
Du kannst die Temperatur anzeigen lassen.
Du kannst die monatliche Zusammenfassung anzeigen.
Was du denn alles gecharged hast.
Dann kannst du dir daraus ausrechnen lassen, was hat das gekostet.
Wenn ich nächstes Jahr mir das dann mal mit Solar-Panels angucke...
Wann ist Fan-Treffen?
Bei einer Million Abos, wenn ich auch Face-Reveal mache.
Kommt aus dann alles.
Ja, beim Italiener auf dem Buchberg.
Genau, da wo jetzt die Pizza 19 Euro kostet.
Das ist mega teuer, Alter.
Ja, was wollte ich gerade sagen?
Genau, kannst du jetzt ausrechnen lassen.
Nächstes Jahr, wenn ich mir das dann mal mit Solar-Panels auf dem Dach angucke.
Und mit eigenem Akku und solchen Geschichten.
Das mache ich aber erst nächstes Jahr.
Dieses Jahr wird das nichts mehr.
Und dann auch noch ein paar andere Räume mit Split-In-Geräte
für die Klimaanlage, Ausrüst und sowas.
Dann kann man das richtig gut ausrechnen.
Dann kann ich dann auch sehen, okay, wie viel habe ich gechargt.
Wie viel habe ich jetzt dadurch quasi gespart.
Beziehungsweise wie viel habe ich davon aus dem Akku
oder aus den Solar-Panels gezogen.
Das ist richtig nice.
Also, dass man das ordentlich auslesen kann, ist für mich ein riesen Pluspunkt.
Und das in Kombinationen.
Wie viel Ampere? 16.
Die gibt es in 16 und 32.
Dementsprechend kommst du am Ende halt auf 11 Kilowatt.
Beziehungsweise mit der 32 auf 22.
Ich habe mich auch erst gefragt, wie das geht.
Ich erkläre euch das mal kurz.
Max Elektrikors am Start.
Max, Max, Max, Max Elektrikors am Start.
Also, wie kommt man auf 11 Kilowatt?
Also, normalerweise.
Und jetzt, bevor ihr sagt, es ist Mist, was ich jetzt erzähle, warte erst mal, bis ich fertig bin.
Normalerweise kriegst du aus einer Steckdose maximal das da raus.
230 Volt und 16 Ampere.
Also sprich, wenn wir jetzt mal alles weglassen, kriegst du 3,6 Kilowatt oder 3,7 Kilowatt raus.
Was du allerdings auch nicht dauerbelasten kannst.
Also, mal angenommen, du hast eine 16 Ampere Sicherung dran.
Ich weiß nicht, es gibt ja genug Steckdosen, die haben sogar nur eine 10 Ampere Sicherung dran.
Aber, mal angenommen, du hast es, es ist das Maximale, was du aus einer normalen Steckdose rausholen kannst.
Das da.
Realistischer betrachtet ist wahrscheinlich eher sowas, wenn du nicht willst, dass es überhitzt oder so.
Jetzt, bei den Dingern ist das anders.
Die werden ja nicht angeschlossen an eine normale Steckdose, sondern die werden entweder angeschlossen an...
Die werden entweder angeschlossen an so eine...
Wie heißt das Ding?
Das, was Beiß sagt.
Diese rote.
Oder aber direkt mit Kabeln vom Elektriker an irgendeinen Verteiler.
Nee, damit fange ich nicht an, Kamil, weil ich da keine Ahnung habe.
Man muss übrigens die Fix-Variante verwenden, falls du die Steckdose nicht verwendest.
Fix-Variante verwenden, falls man irgendwo Fördergelder beantragen will.
Es gibt zwar keine Bundes...
Leute, ich sage euch, diese ganze Fördergeld-Thematik bei Elektroautos ist unglaublich kompliziert.
Ich blick da jetzt auch nur jetzt durch, weil ich es mir gekauft habe und danach nie wieder.
Also bundesweite Förderung für Wallboxen oder Chargers daheim gibt es nicht mehr.
Gab es letztes Jahr noch, gibt es nicht mehr.
Es ist ausgelaufen, sind die Fördermittel erschöpft.
Aber es gibt oftmals noch Förderprogramme.
Entweder von Ländern oder manchmal auch von der jeweiligen Stadt, wo man wohnt.
Da müsst ihr gucken.
Aber was alle Förderprogramme gemeinhaben ist, dass du einen fest installierten Charger brauchst.
Zu 99%.
Ja, Förderungen werden jedes Jahr schlechter.
Dieses Jahr ist die Förderung für Autos noch gut.
Die Förderung für Charger gibt es nicht mehr.
Also du brauchst einen fest installierten Charger für 99% aller Förderungsregeln.
Der muss fest installiert sein.
Du darfst keinen Charger nehmen, den du theoretisch abmachen kannst.
Warum?
Wer sich das ausgedacht hat?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber nimmst du den hier, kannst du keine Förderung beantragen.
Falls du Förderung beantragen kannst, nimmst du den hier und lässt dir den vom Elektriker anschließen.
Kannst du Förderung beantragen, wenn es das bei dir gibt.
Also der hier hat diesen Anschluss.
So und im Endeffekt alles, was der Elektriker machen muss, ist das Anschließen.
Weiß ich, ob man hier ordentliche Bilder nochmal hat.
Ja, das ist, das ist der, Alter, das mussten die auch jetzt erst einblenden.
So, hat man da mal irgendwie ordentliche Bilder von?
Ne, natürlich, natürlich nicht, ja doch, hier, hier ist schlecht, schlecht ausgeschnittenes GIF.
Ob man das hier irgendwo sieht.
Ah, da hat man es gesehen, guckt.
Das muss der Elektriker anschließen.
Und ganz im Ernst, das sind vier Adern.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die dran müssen, ist aber nicht mein Problem.
Der Elektriker weiß das schon.
Schon fix und fertig mit Adern, Endhülsen drauf und alles.
Also im Prinzip muss der eigentlich nur vom Anschluss im Keller das verlängern,
irgendeinen Zwischenverteiler oder wie man das nennt, irgendeine Zwischenbox setzen,
dort das miteinander verbinden und fertig.
Also das sollte, würde ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten, jeder Elektriker hinkriegen,
ob das sich jetzt auf Wallboxen spezialisiert hat oder nicht.
Was mir meiner erzählen wollte.
Und deswegen fand ich es halt kacke, dass ich da wieder so, dass die wieder versucht haben,
mich so zu gibäten, so mit, ah, ob das geht und ah, da müssen wir gucken.
Nein, natürlich geht das.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob wir elektrisch bewandte Leute, BlueSky könnte sein,
so aus dem Chat, bewandte Leute im Chat haben.
Also das muss doch jeder Elektriker hinkriegen, mir sowas anzuschließen.
Das ist so, wie wenn ich sagen würde, kannst du mir eine SATA Festplatte anschließen oder so.
Da sag ich ja auch, mach auf, mach auf und ich stöpsel an.
Ich glaube, die wollten mich schlicht und ergreifend gibäten.
So, ach ja, ich wollte euch ja erklären, wie man auf 11 Kilowatt kommt.
Also das liegt daran, normale Steckdose, sagen wir mal realistisch,
unter Dauerbelastung eher sowas, so 2,8 Kilowatt oder 2800.
Allerdings, das hier, diese Dinger sind ja 400 Volt und 16 Ampere.
Und da werdet ihr feststellen, das reicht immer noch nicht.
Das sind immer nur 6,4 Kilowatt.
Aber, aber, jetzt, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's.
Man muss das irgendwie mal 1,5 hoch 2 oder ich kann die Formel nicht,
nee nicht mal 3, es ist nicht mal 3.
Es ist nicht mal 3, es ist irgendwie mal 1,5 hoch 2.
Irgendwie so ganz komische Formel, frag mich jetzt nicht.
Oder Wurzel, ist es Wurzel 3, kann auch sein, nee, mal Wurzel aus 3, okay.
Mal, mal Wurzel aus 3, exellent, genau das.
Wie komme ich auf mal 1,5 hoch 2?
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich weiß, irgendwie habe ich gestern.
So, also so geht das und dann kommt man auf 11000, ja 11000.
11000 85,1251684 kommt man an.
Und deswegen sind das 11, haben die Dinger maximale Leistung 11 Kilowatt.
Weil, weil 400 Volt, 16 Ampere und das Ganze dann irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht, warum Wurzel 3 ehrlich gesagt.
Weil drei Phasen oder so und ich habe aber keine Ahnung,
was das bedeutet bzw. was es für Auswirkungen hat, weil ich kein Elektriker bin.
Dafür braucht man eine extra Genehmigung.
Nein, du brauchst keine extra Genehmigung, du musst nur Bescheid sagen, dass du eine hast.
Bei 22 Kilowatt brauchst du eine extra Genehmigung, bei 11 nicht.
Und ich habe das mal ausgerechnet, das ist okay.
Mein Fiat 500e hat, glaube ich, eine 42 Kilowattstunden Batterie.
Ja, und das kann man jetzt ja über den Daumen gepeilt ausrechnen.
Und nein, wir rechnen da jetzt nicht ein, was du vielleicht noch an Verlusten hast beim Laden,
was da an Wärme verloren geht und hast du nicht gesehen.
Sondern wir machen das jetzt wirklich, richtig, richtig nubisch.
Wo habe ich denn jetzt hier mal ein Gramm ausgerechnet?
Ja. Okay, wie war das nochmal? Mal Wurzel 3.
Five-Hetter-Time vom Chat wieder.
Nur mal so ganz, ganz grob über den Daumen gepeilt.
Also, wenn du da, wenn das Ding 11 Kilowatt Leistung ja rausbekommt,
also Watt ist ja quasi Energie pro Zeit schon.
Deswegen macht es ja auch immer keinen Sinn zu sagen,
was manche Leute machen, ist es so Watt pro Sekunde oder so, es ergibt keinen Sinn.
Also Watt ist ja schon Energie pro Sekunde.
Ursprünglich war es mal Joules pro Sekunde.
Und also kannst du im Endeffekt, und das hier ist auch,
und das muss man vielleicht auch nochmal dabei sagen, weil das auch einige Leute verwirrt,
der Unterschied zwischen Kilowattstunden und Kilometer pro Stunde,
auch wenn man das vielleicht ähnlich ausspricht, ist was komplett anderes.
Das eine ist Kilometer durch die Zeit, und das hier ist Kilowattmalzeit.
Also das hier ist eine Menge.
Und dementsprechend macht es auch Sinn, dass du Batterien oder Akkus in Kilowattstunden angibst,
weil das heißt im Endeffekt einfach was reinpasst.
Also die Energiemenge, die das speichern kann.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun, wie lange du da was rausziehen kannst.
Wie lange hängt dann davon ab, ja wie viel Leistung denn du brauchst aus der Batterie.
Das ist die Menge, das ist die Energiemenge, die reinpasst.
Ein Herd hat auch einen 400 Volt Anschluss, ja.
Meistens, das ist dann auch so ein rotes Ding.
Genau, und das heißt, man kann das jetzt relativ einfach rechnen,
wenn man es nicht so genau machen will.
Kannste theoretisch sagen, okay, wie lange brauche ich, um das aufzuladen?
Naja, vier Stunden ungefähr, wenn man sagt, man hat noch ein bisschen Verlust und sonst was.
Dreieinhalb, vier Stunden oder so müsste das dauernd aufzuladen ungefähr.
Allerdings lädst du ja meistens nicht von 0 auf 100 auf,
sondern du lädst von 30 auf 80 oder so.
Also ich würde mal sagen, wahrscheinlich ist das Ding in zweieinhalb Stunden wieder einsatzbereit,
wenn man das damit auflädt.
Was auch für mich der Grund ist, weil der Fiat hat jetzt ja keine super Riesenbatterie,
das ist auch ein kleines Auto.
Zweieinhalb Stunden irgendwie braucht das dann zum Aufladen.
Deswegen nehme ich auch die 11 Kilowatt-Variante und nicht die 22.
Das reicht, ganz ehrlich, in zweieinhalb Stunden wieder aufgeladen ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, du hast recht, wird es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wie gesagt, das ist auch noch ganz grob gerechnet.
Der Akku lädt ja nicht immer gleich schnell.
Aber so über den Daumen gepeilt.
Über den Daumen gepeilt ist das Ding zumindest in zweieinhalb Stunden kannst du damit wieder fahren
zum Einkaufen und alles und auch ein bisschen weiter.
Das ist okay.
Du kannst den Charger in der Küche anschließen.
Nee, da ist mein Herd dran.
Ich will nicht mein Herd abziehen, um den Charger anzuschließen.
Das wäre irgendwie ein bisschen...
So, so sieht es aus.
Also das Ding will ich eingebaut haben.
Das Ding will ich eingebaut haben.
Und wie gesagt, das müsste jeder Elektriker hinkriegen und mich ärgert es einfach,
dass ich schon wieder versucht werde zu gibaten mit irgendwie ja, ob das dann geht
und ach, ob das dann der Charger...
Das ist alles Blödsinn.
Also mal ganz im Ernst.
Das kriegt jeder Elektriker angeschlossen, so wie jeder, der ein bisschen IT-technisch,
was keine SATA-Platte anschließen kann.
Ich glaube, der große Unterschied ist das nicht.
Das sind vier Kabel, die an die richtigen Stellen müssen.
Vielleicht musst du es noch mal verlängern ein bisschen.
Das kriegt jeder Elektriker hin.
100 pro.
Das denke...
Das wage ich einschätzen zu können als Nicht-Elektriker, dass das jeder Elektriker hinkriegt.
Die Leute am Telefon haben doch auch keine Ahnung.
Gut, dann sollen sie aber nicht so tun, als hätten sie Ahnung, beziehungsweise mich gibaten.
Dann sollen sie es halt sagen, dass sie keine Ahnung haben.
Gut.
So, also so sieht es aus.
Gab es sonst noch irgendwelche Questions?
GoWizard, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also, bis ich die Wallbox dran habe, mache ich es halt mit dem normalen Ladekabel.
Was dabei ist.
Das lädt dann aber halt richtig lang.
Topics, danke für den Sub.
Das hatten wir schon, das hatten wir auch schon.
Ja, damit habe ich mich auch schon beschäftigt.
Das ist diese Zertifikatsgeschichte.
Dass du quasi dein CO2, was du sparst, verkaufen kannst an irgendwelche Unternehmen, die gerne die Umwelt verschmutzen.
Und dann kriegst du ein bisschen Kohle für.
Eigentlich Five-Hat-Idee.
Das geht ja erst seit diesem Jahr oder seit letztem Jahr für Privatpersonen.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache, wenn man es denn schon hat.
Dann ist zumindest Wartungsarbeiten und so quasi, hat sich schon bezahlt.
So.
Ja, weil es ein bisschen teuer ist.
Und es sich für meine Fahr, wie nennt man das, Fahr-Charakteristik, nee, also für meine Fahrgewohnheiten überhaupt nicht eignet.
Geschweige denn, dass es in Parkplätze gescheit passt und so.
Nee, nee, das Auto ist schon genau richtig für mich.
Hast du schon die Apis vom Auto gecheckt?
Ja, habe ich.
Uconnect hat keine offizielle Api Docs.
Aber Uconnect hat eine Webseite.
Offizielle Api Docs gibt es natürlich nicht.
Aber es gibt eine Webseite, über die man alles machen kann.
Und wenn es eine Webseite gibt, dann wisst ihr genauso gut wie ich, entweder pause ich die Webseite oder mach nen Headless Chrome.
Oder aber ich guck in den Developer Tools, was die eigentlich zu ihrem Server schicken.
Also wenn es noch keine Fiat Uconnect Integration für Home Assistant gibt, dann bau ich eine.
Und dann hab ich mein Auto, also dann hab ich mein Auto im Home Assistant drin.
Dann hab ich meine Charge, meine Wallbox, mein Charger in Home Assistant drin.
Und dann kann ich alles mögliche automatisieren, was ich will.
Vor allem in Kombination mit CarPlay kann man dann wahrscheinlich richtig coole Sachen machen.
So nach dem Motto, wenn CarPlay Connected ist und ich im WLAN zu Hause bin.
Dann, was weiß ich, vielleicht lass ich mir irgendwann mal ein automatisches Tür oder Garagentor oder was auch immer öffnerein machen.
Dann kann ich das damit auslösen.
Oder ich kann mir Ansagen lassen, was ich auch machen könnte zum Beispiel.
Das ist das erste was mir einfällt, ich komm da bestimmt noch auf bessere Ideen.
Zum Beispiel, ich hab gecharged, ich setz mich ins Auto, schmeiß mein Handy in die Ladeschale, sprich CarPlay Connected.
Dann sagt er mir an, was weiß ich, wie viel das letzte Aufladen gekostet hat oder so.
Oder wie lange er gebraucht hat oder irgendwas.
Irgendwie kannst du super drauf reagieren, das ist eigentlich eine coole Geschichte.
Und wenn beides drin ist, hab ich auch Zugriff auf die Daten aus Uconnect und von meinem Aufladegerät.
Also da kann man sicherlich coole Sachen machen.
Ich könnte sogar solche Dinge machen, wie das, mein Handy überträgt ja wo ich bin, an mein Home Assistant.
Und ich könnte zum Beispiel solche Dinge machen, wie wenn ich auf dem Weg nach Hause bin, dann und CarPlay Connected ist,
weil ansonsten bin ich im Zug, da interessiert mich das nicht.
Also quasi, wenn meine Travel Direction im Home Assistant Towards Home ist und CarPlay Connected ist,
dann schickt sie mir eine Nachricht, ob der Parkplatz vom Haus frei ist.
Ansonsten weiß ich, ob ich Hufte aufmachen muss, auf den Parkplatz fahren muss oder direkt vor's Haus fahren kann und sowas.
Da kann man richtig coole Automatisierungen machen.
Da muss ich in Zukunft mal gucken, was man da so alles schönes, schönes treiben kann.
Ja, für was steht das?
Uh, keine Ahnung.
Für Fiat.
Ah, für Ubisoft.
Oh ja, hoffentlich haben die...
Ich hoffe ja nicht, dass Ubisoft was mit meiner Autobedienung zu tun hat.
Nö, habe ich nicht. Nicht, dass ich wüsste, wo hat man denn sowas normalerweise.
Außer in der Küche für ein Herd.
Also, ist mir nicht bewusst, dass ich sowas habe.
In der Garage, meine Garage hat keinen Stromanschluss.
Garage ist reines Abstellding bisher gewesen.
Vielleicht bekommt ihr in Zukunft noch einen.
Die Werkstatt hinten vielleicht, aber die Werkstatt hinten hat auch nur eine ganz normale 230 Volt Schuko-Steckdose.
Bisschen laut, hä?
Was hatten wir alles schon?
Der Guido, danke für den Sub.
Massive Subscriptions hier wieder.
Danke an alle, die ich übersehen habe.
Diese auch.
Habe ich euch das jemals erzählt.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Recycle
wahr Ri
Man
Lam
auf deutsch hast und dann meint er subskribieren
aber ich mach grad alles klar, subskribieren jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
Leute ich weiß nicht was diese Fragen also was genau wollt ihr wissen ich hab wurde
jetzt schon gefragt warum kein tesla warum kein porsche warum kein e-smart
das kannst du weiterführen mit jedem autotyp mit jeder automarke mit jedem
autohersteller
warum kein fahrrad warum keine inlineskates oder kein longboard
wobei longboard ist glaube ich überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt
warum kein roller warum kein privater helikopter ja kann er alles heutzutage
kannst du auch an der normalen steckdose laden mit dem mit dem was für
einem booster der an der normalen steckdose laden ist halt langsam der
booster kann noch so viel boosten mehr als 230 volt mal 16 ampere maximal wird
es da nicht rauskriegen weil woher soll der was boosten
eigener zug ja das das wärs noch und wie gesagt dauerbelastung dauerbelastung 16
ampere normalen steckdose will man oder sollte man ja nicht machen
topics danke für den sub hier habe ich schon gesehen aber trotzdem
ja nächstes jahr aber erst und ich weiß ja nicht ob das wirklich dazu
kommen wird also ich habe für nächstes jahr geplant also ein bisschen geguckt
habe ich dieses jahr schon ich weiß beispielsweise auch in welche richtung
ich hatte letztens ich weiß ich hätte euch gezeigt also nicht bei meinem haus
oder bei einem anderen haus ich weiß die seite nicht mehr ich habe letztens so
eine seite gehabt da konnte man den sonnenstand für verschiedene richtungen
auf häuserdächern sich anzeigen lassen und ausrechnen lassen wie viel
quadratmeter solar panels ungefähr was bringen konnte man auch so eine map
konnte man quasi dann einzeichnen und er hat dann geguckt wie ist der
sonnenstand das jahr über so und da habe ich mir das habe ich mir das mal
angeguckt das heißt ich weiß in welche richtung das gehen muss die solar panels
bei mir auf dem haus und wo man theoretisch was machen könnte also wenn
ich ganz extrem übertreibe was ich nicht machen werde das was ich nicht machen
werde weil mir das viel zu teuer ist also ich könnte auf der einen dachhälfte
was machen also ich habe ja kein flaches dach ich habe so ein normales dach so
und so ein häuschen dach halt kein flaches dach wie nennt man das spitzes
dach wie heißt ein normales dach giebel dach
giebel dach mr spiel unke weiß bescheid giebel dach sattel da so immer so ein
normales dach halt also das heißt ich könnte es nur sinnvoll auf einer seite
machen vom dach aber was ich machen könnte ich könnte es auf dem stall
gegenüber halbwegs sinnvoll machen und ich könnte es theoretisch auch noch auf
der garage halbwegs sinnvoll machen weil das alles in die richtung geht und da
keine schatten davor sind großartig aber da bezahle ich mich dumm und dämlich
was ich machen werde ist wahrscheinlich erst mal auf der einen dachhälfte und
dann muss ich noch gucken mit welcher mit welchem akku und und wie das da muss ich
mich wirklich im detail mit beschäftigen dass ich da genau durch blicke weil
ansonsten wenn du da also eins kann ich euch jetzt aus der aus dieser erfahrung
schon wieder sagen ja was elektroauto angeht wenn ihr selbst euch nicht damit
beschäftigt ihr werdet an allen stellen schiebtet und beschissen wirklich das
mit dem elektriker war wieder so der tropfen auf das was fast zum überlaufen
gebracht an jeder stelle wenn du nicht genau weißt was sache ist du wirst
schiebtet an an jeder ecke erzählen dir irgendwas was ja sinnvoll klickt
wenn man selbst nicht weiß und dann im endeffekt bezahlst du dann tausende
euro mehr als sein müsste also muss ich mit grad mit so teuren
sachen muss man sich vorher einfach beschäftigen und selbst ein bisschen
durch blick haben dass die eigentlich so sehr zubäden können
ja das gucke ich mir nächstes jahr an und in kombination in kombination mit der
solaranlage offen also mit dem mit der photovoltaik nennt man es ja anlage auf
dem dach werde ich dann auch mal gucken ob ich noch mehr räume innen drinnen
anschließen lassen anschließen lassen an meine klimaanlage aktuell hat die
klimaanlage ja nur zwei räume mein arbeitszimmer man schlafzimmer das so
eine split klimaanlage somit im außen gerät und innen gerät und die kann so
weit ich weiß fünf innen geräte von denen irgendwie glaube ich nur zwei
standardmäßig an gleichzeitig an sein können aber das reicht ja und ich ich
möchte noch andere ich will das beispielsweise das wohnzimmer noch
schlafzimmer unten noch und ja mal gucken auch noch auch noch da
anschließen weil dann habe ich die möglichkeit komplett zu heizen und zu
kühlen mit dem ding weil gasheizung ihr wisst ich habe eine gasheizung wer weiß
was gas in zwei drei jahren kostet dann ist es wahrscheinlich zumindest ist es
nicht gut wenn es ist auf jeden fall gut wenn man alternativen hat und zumal das
den kühlen und heizen kann ist ja da auch nichts verschenkt weil kühlen
wirst du im sommer in zukunft definitiv mehr brauchen so und dann werde ich das
so weit im haus installieren lassen die räume bieten sich halt an weil da muss
ich nicht großartig röhren an an durch räume legen und dann habe ich die
möglichkeit quasi mit strom zu kühlen und zu heizen und das in kombination mit
mit parzola panels und im akku dann kann ich theoretisch quasi meinen
eigenen strom verheizen und verkühlen
was ist denn der unterschied zwischen einem sonnenkollektor und einem solar
an die sonnenkollektor ist das was ein wasser war macht oder das ist das stell
da muss ja wasser da muss ja rohre und so noch aufs dach legen ich glaube das
wird dann ultra teuer warum kein teleporter ganz ehrlich sobald private
teleporter gibt da bin ich sofort dabei wobei ne da bin ich nicht sofort dabei
weil ihr wisst ja was teleporter machen es ist nicht so dass teleporter euch von
a nach b transportieren teleporter zerstören euch an a und erstellen euch
neu an b das heißt ihr sterbt an a und ihr werdet neu mit einem 3d drucker
quasi zusammengesetzt an b das ist eigentlich was total abartig ist wenn
man sich überlegt teleporter und und was passiert wenn der teleporter euch an a
nicht zerstört dann gibt es auf einmal zweimal also sobald du teleporter hast
kannst du auch leute eins zu eins klonen also das ist teleporter hört sich cool
an aber wenn man sich mal so ein bisschen überlegt was es eigentlich heißt
sich teleportieren zu lassen ist es ziemlich ekliche und fragwürdige
angelegenheit und vor allem was passiert wenn wenn er ein paar sachen nicht
richtig zusammensetzt
also ich würde auf jeden fall teleporta generationen abwarten bevor ich den
bevor ich mir sowas hole ich meine ist ja logisch ihr müsst quasi
nämlich komplett alle informationen die man braucht um euch wieder aufbauen zu
können müssen quasi an der quelle eingelesen werden
inklusive quasi eurem letzten hier snapshot also komplett komplett den
aufbau alle informationen die man braucht dann werdet ihr des integriert
ihr werdet quasi ja ihr löst euch quasi auf an an punkt a dann werden alle
informationen die man dazu braucht um euch zu rekonstruieren übertragen
maximal mit lichtgeschwindigkeit logischerweise wenn an empfang an b und
dann werdet ihr dort mit einem 3d drucke oder was auch immer
rekonstruiert also sprich seid ihr überhaupt noch der gleiche nach dem
teleport ist dann vielleicht irgendwas anders ja und stellt euch mal wirklich
vor dass ihr seid da nicht wirklich weg an a und es gibt euch beide also das
teleport ist wirklich fragwürdige geschichte
ne noch nicht wer weiß aber ihr kennt mich ich trinke eigentlich so gut wie
gar nichts das einzige mal wenn ich was trinke vielleicht ein bisschen was an
weihnachten oder silvester und da eigentlich auch kaum was ja es ist mega
teuer es ist mega teuer
und wenn strom 73 cent da kann ich ja schneller bei uns am charg da kann ich
ja billiger am charger in der stadt tanken als bei mir daheim
muss man kurz gucken strompreise seit man ja harnau gibt es irgendwie
kosten das
ja das kann es nicht sein
hier 29 cent
29 cent
das ist aber ganz schön viel ist als dreifache strompreis was check 24 okay
wir gucken uns mal
posterzahl ja nehmen wir mal frankfurt 603 29 ja mal ganz technik was ich habe
so das ist alles immer jibayt da oben das ist alles immer werbung kann man das
ohne werbung bonus nicht mit einrechnen
öko nachhaltig da eigentlich würde es mich interessieren aber ich bin auch auf
mein eigenem geldbeutel bedacht also interessiert es mir nicht
so kostet jetzt was wo stehts tarife und tarife und preis details alter
das schon ordentlich ok wir gucken wir gucken mal
harnau
was ist das für komische seite was interessiert mich der du tun
das ist aber schon teuer leute ich kann was ist denn das für eine logik das heißt
am charger bei mir in der stadt ist es billiger aufzuladen da kostet nämlich
plus 39 cent für die kilowattstunde am charger im ort ist es billiger aufzuladen
demnächst als daheim sehe ich das richtig gut die werden den preis am
charger wahrscheinlich auch erhöhen demnächst ist ja krass normalerweise ist
es daheim am billigsten gewesen tja das hier ist immer krass wie teuer das ist
alter worte oder gaspreis alter ich will nicht wissen was ich dann alles
neues zusätzliches bezahlen muss ende des jahres terabyte reichen da nicht ja
da brauchst du noch ganz andere größenordnung was ja nicht funktioniert
mittlerweile bist du vielleicht wirklich mit der oldschool technologie billiger
als das was der strom aus der steckdose kostet wobei gut mein diesel und bensin
die kosten halt auch mega viel aktuell
ja noch noch wahrscheinlich habt ihr einfach einen vertrag der möglichst
lang läuft wahrscheinlich wird es auch bald dort erhöht
ich habe schon geguckt in so einer in so einer chart schmepp nach lidl all die
edeka und sonst was die charger anbieten natürlich viele leden wollen
mittlerweile dass man da auch einkauft wenn man an den charger geht also gut
was heißt viele leden wollen dass das oder beim ikea ja also viele die leden
wollten dass schon immer dass man dort einkauft wenn man dort lädt und es gibt
halt immer noch ein paar leute die fahren da hin und laden auf und ging da
nicht einkaufen wobei man halt sagen muss das rechnet sich dann unterm strich
nicht und irgendwann gibt sie kostenlose lademöglichkeiten nicht mehr also ich
finde man sollte zumindest so fair sein das zu kombinieren
ja dann gehe ich dann halt zum zum lidl einkaufen anstatt zum aldi wenn ich da
laden kann
solar lohnt sich hauptsächlich wenn du selbst nutzt das beste was du machen
kannst ist ein selbst den strom den du selbst produzierst selbst benutzen das
ist das beste was du machen kannst ach nee du meinst zurück
nee das lohnt also das kann man machen da gibt es auch ein bisschen was für aber
großartig lohnen tut sich das nicht wenn er hat noch was übrig hast ok aber
wirklich lohnen richtig tut sich das nur wenn du den kram selbst benutzt das
heißt es hat auch keinen sinn das wahnsinnig zu überdimensionieren so dass
du was einspeisen kannst also lohnen tut sich das nur wenn du möglichst viel
selbst verbrauchst und das geht wahrscheinlich auch nur wenn nun wenn
nun halbwegs brauchbaren akku hast weil die ja auch mal zu zeiten wo die sonne
nicht scheint was brauchst
ja das aber damit muss ich mich im detail nächstes jahr beschäftigen
das kriege ich dieses jahr nicht mehr hin
alles klar so also du yourself storage server allein schon in so einem gehäuse
würde ich kein storage server bauen aber gucken mal gucken was ich dazu
sage aber ich glaube nicht ich skippe ich skippe das mal schnell ich glaube nicht
dass mir das gefällt nee das gefällt ich mein das geht noch das ist ein
fractal design r5 oder sowas gehäuse oder sie ziemlich zieht sie ziemlich
danach aus oder ist es das ja ja ja das ist das gehäuse habe ich schon seit vier
vier pc generationen wo ist wo ist es
ja wie parts used wo ist das gehäuse keckel parts used gehäuse gehört
natürlich eindeutig nicht zu parts used sind sind für uns ein gehäuse ist ja
nicht benutzt worden also mit diesen gehäusen geht das noch
halbwegs da kannst du immerhin war das er heute im stream schon dran
ausgebremst wenn die energie wende anderdings
oder es ist bestimmt wieder so ein video oder wo dann irgendwelche leute von
twitter am ende kommen und sagen ja ja nein ein klimawandel hat schon immer
gegeben oder sowas gibt es ja immer noch genug
aber wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben also
so ja also die gut das gehäuse geht ja noch weil du kriegst die festplatten
halbwegs gescheit rein und raus aber das sind keine wechselrahmen hier
wohlgemerkt vielleicht verkauft es der hersteller so aber ist es nicht also
ganz im ernst
ich bin kein fan von diesen gehäusen für sowas ich bin der meinung wenn man
einen storage server baut der sollte an der front ordentliche laufwerkschächte
haben und sollte so einen wie heißt das so einen hotplug tray wechselrahmen
haben alles andere ist doof wie oft wechselst du deine platten nicht oft ich
hoffe nicht dass sie oft kaputt gehen aber wenn du in storage server hast mit
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 platten da kannst du davon ausgehen dass öfters mal was ist
acht platten gibt ja sogar irgendwo in rechner ja müssen wir mal gucken
rechner wie oft im durchstehen was kaputt also ich sag dir mal ich sag mal so wenn
du wirklich acht platten hast alle eins bis zwei jahre ist auf jeden fall mal
was kaputt und dann musst du da dran wenn du
pech hast auch öfters weil die platten zum ähnlichen zeitpunkt gekauft wurden
sondern musst du da dran und dann hast du das problem je nachdem wo du stehen
hast muss es gehäult also muss erst mal ausschalten das ist ja schon mal das
erste du musst ausschalten du musst abmachen du musst das gehäuse rausziehen
du musst aufmachen du musst gucken welche der platten davon die dein rate
meldet oder was auch immer du verwendest oder dein dein zumindest ein
betriebssystem ist kaputt ist denn die platte die kaputt ist da musste die
raus sind musste die musste wahrscheinlich das ganze tray raus machen
ich weiß nicht wie das geht kabel anschließen wieder rein man das ist ab
fack es hat schon einen grund warum die ganzen nassgeräte auch für einen heimbereich
die dir kaufen können hotswap ramen vorne dran haben weil es einfach die mit
abstand beste art und weise ist magnetplatten zu tauschen
ja natürlich ist es teurer aber du brauchst doch keine acht festplatten
acht festplatten ist totaler overkill 3 reicht komplett du musst noch nicht mal
du musst auch nicht mal rate 5 machen rate 5 ist eh so ein fragwürdiges ding
mit drei platten geht es gerade noch so also rate 5 mit drei platten ist das
minimale was möglich ist und das maximale was man machen sollte rate 5
mit mehr als drei platten ist ja fast schon ganze ganze gleich rate null
machen naja vielleicht bisschen übertrieben aber ja würde ich den
würde ich nicht machen ich würde in der heutigen zeit wahrscheinlich
eh kein rate mehr machen sondern die platten einfach lose
zusammenhängen oder aber in rate 1 machen und ein als stand by drinnen
lassen wenn man es wirklich verfügbar haben will
aber acht platten würde ich auf jeden fall nicht rein machen und
dementsprechend und dementsprechend reicht auch ein kleineres gehäuse und dann
kann man sich ordentliche wechselrahmen leisten
ich will auf meinem nass keinen fortnite spielen
hattet ihr auch schon immer mal das bedürfnis fortnite auf eurem nass zu
spielen ja das macht das hier macht mit wechsel wechselrahmen auch nicht viel
sinn also das hier geht noch irgendwo wenn man
ein rack hat mit schienen und den server rausziehen kann und dann relativ easy
wechseln aber das ist ja daheim gerade weil du komplett komplett ist das was
ist denn das 80 cm oder so das ist eine normale bautiefe du brauchst ein
komplettes full size rack dafür was auch die wenigsten leute daheim stehen
haben oder aber du hast es halt oben irgendwo
auf dem tisch liegen ja geht auch aber trotzdem du musst wahrscheinlich auch
ausschalten wechseln ist alles wechselrahmen ist das beste was du
brauchst das probleme sind die kleinen lüfter warum das laut ja das ist laut
das willst du nicht neben dir auf dem schreibtisch stehen haben die dinger
sind weder energie optimiert also stromverbrauch im stromverbrauch günstig
noch sind die leise die dinger sind dafür gedacht im keller im rechenzentrum
zu stehen wo es keiner mitkriegt nach möglichkeit auch noch mit einer
klimaanlage dass das quasi von der einen seite kalte luft anzieht und auf
der anderen seite warme luft abgibt was du daheim auch nicht als aber in dem
fall bei einer kiste kein problem ist und saubere luft genau
ohne staub was du daheim auch nicht hast wo sei ich das was hatte ich für
problem damit ich meine das macht auch ganz guten eindruck
ja damit hätte ja auch keiner rechnen können wenn man sich ein rechenzentrum
hardware kauft dass sie laut ist also das wäre und ich kann nicht sein also
kennt man nicht drauf kommen können
moin schaenlohr nun ich könnte das transplant all those parts into a
monogatte ausprobieren probieren gegenüber studieren auf other flaws mit
der system that i decide to start from scratch and build it better außerdem
war der eindeutig zu wenig rgb gramm das stimmt und lüfter
that supports as many drives as my diy solution would cost somewhere between
one to two thousand dollars before drives you know many tech youtubers have built
quote-unquote ist aber ist es ist aber also preisleistungstechnisch sind die
technology dinger ok für das was man bekommt ich meine die hardware an sich
rein von den specs die ist natürlich zu teuer ja da sind dann
irgendwelche dual core hier ja die pentium silber sonst was drin aber die
kombination aus der hardware dem gehäuse dass es halt einfach funktioniert und
den vielen features die das technology zeug hat ist das ok also wenn ich wenn
ich mir ohne groß nachzudenken nass daheim hinstellen wollen würde dann
würde ich wahrscheinlich auch sonst ein other cheating nehmen
two thousand dollars before drives now many tech youtubers have built quote
unquote budget storage servers touting they cost only 1500 dollars and then
proceed to pull out ten plus thousand dollars worth of drives provided free
from the likes of seagate or western digital but the point of the last build
in this one is to put together an 80 plus terabyte server all in including
platten sind das 14 tera alter was der wilde allen ernstes acht mal 14
terabyte reinhauen ok der hat der hat gewisse storage anforderungen so wie es
aussieht 15 dollar price point die go a little over budget this time by around
100 bucks ok ne es sind nur sechs es sind naja
viernachtstherabyte das ist schon mal was result was well worth it just know i
was very careful da hat bestimmt fünf jusnet accounts und und premium torrent
und direkt download und was auch immer der ist den ganzen tag nur am saugen
with component selection and made sure i spend the budget on what i felt
provided the best value at the current time to prove this point was actually
in und linux distribution runterladen logischerweise in talks with seagate on
possibly helping out with the build but they could only send out their crazy
expensive 18 terabyte drives and because those weren't anywhere near
das haben sie geschrieben für so can you share also da wollte der wollte youtube
bonus nutzen kann man machen warum nicht ich meine ich bin immer noch froh dass
ich damals die 1080 ti von nvidia für
für paar tweets und und in video bekommen hab die habe ich bis heute also
das war eines der langlebigsten grafikkarten die ich je hatte also das
war tatsächlich mal ein sponsoring was sich wirklich gelohnt hat
anywhere near the dollar per terabyte target i was trying to hit i begrudgingly
decline their offer with the experience of building and configuring the last
server and with my new goal of improving it in every way i could i started to part
out my new system now version 1.0 used i hope er benutzt ecc ram und zfs weil
wenn nicht wenn er ins zfs vor ins ins frinas forum geht und schreibt er
benutzt zfs ohne ecc ram da kommen die ganzen selbsternannte frinas elite und
erzählt ihm wie unmenschlich unwürdig das ist zfs ohne ecc ram zu verwenden was
natürlich schwachsinn ist zfs ist auch nicht schlechter als normales
dateisystem ohne ecc ram also
das ist jetzt nicht als wird es dadurch kaputt gehen du merkst manche fehler
vielleicht nicht was du bei anderen dateisystem schon mal gar nicht merkt
also es ist nicht schlechter es ist nicht so dass du das dadurch quasi ohne
ecc ram mehr kaputt geht das wird immer so dargestellt ist es ja nicht der
blödsinn du merkst vielleicht manche fehler nicht also es ist schon im
prinzip empfehlenswert gerade bei so großen mengen das dann mit ecc ram zu
machen wenn man zfs verwendet aber es stirbt auch keiner wenn man mal zfs
ohne zcc ram verwendet dadurch geht nicht mehr kaputt du merkst vielleicht
manche sachen nicht was du bei anderen sachen erst gar nicht die chance
hättest zu merken ein paar noch mal 20 sekunden zurück
meinst du dem ram
ist es ecc ram ja müsste hier ist noch ein zusätzlicher zusätzlicher chip
als man das überhaupt daran erkennen kann leute wie erkennt ihr ob das ecc
ram ist
daran dass es neuen dass es einer mehr ist
der chat wieder reise fs wisst ihr überhaupt dass der typ der reise fs
programmiert hat oder erfunden hat im knast sitzt weil er seine frau umgebracht
hat also dass ich glaube das ist ja schon eine weile her ist glaube ich gar
nicht mehr so in den köpfen der leute drinnen der typ hat seine frau umgebracht
der reise fs entwickler ja ja genau der
der ist
er wurde wegen des mordes an seiner ehefrau verurteilt und sitzt gerade im knast
alter chelor jetzt tschöner muss immer so irgendwie die edge die sachen
teilweise schreiben
every way i could i started to part out my new system now version 1.0 used a
prebuilt cembro nr 12000 server that was insanely cheap offering pretty much
everything other than ram and drives for around 130 dollars it was very plug and
play but the form factor and hardware had a lot of limitations so for this build i
went more custom was denn das kurs das wird mich jetzt interessieren wo das
kurse kurse limitations hatte in meinen
naja pick out each component individually now this did cause more work in terms of
set up and configuring it but the end result was well worth it in my opinion
okay auf geht's also das gehäuse finde ich super wie gesagt ich habe diese
fractal design gehäuse schon seit drei oder vier pc generation hat immer
aktuell stehen sogar zwei nebeneinander hier nebeneinander
hier neben am schreibtisch eins neuer bisschen eine generation aber für so ein
system würde ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht unbedingt nicht also mir wieder
streben wir wieder streben storage server ohne wechselrahmen version 2.0
offers the ability to expand in the future well beyond what version 1.0 was
capable of the first purchase i ended up making was for the cpu and motherboard
after looking at a bunch of different options i ended up pulling the trigger
on this combo that came out of an old hp z4 20 workstation i only paid a little
over 60 dollars ich spule mal ein bisschen vor wo man dann wirklich sieht was sache
ist tons of pci expansions thoughts which is great in case i want to do
something sound a three gigabit work standard a billable amount okay it's a
ceramics and it gets the job done my search massive massive flüfter support a
ton of drives which for he ended up settling a little dusty so i figured
the best
ist das irgendwie giftig oder so ich meine das ist waschmittel
in all seriousness this was really dirty just look at this fan filter i
immediately wash these out off camera everything else i just gave a good once
over with some paper towels and all-purpose cleaner yes i know i could
have hosed the after a bunch of price and in this year was richtigen
ist ja was richtig nice ist für solche also ja ok für solche sachen jetzt
vielleicht übertrieben aber was richtig nice ist zum sauber machen so so eine
druckluftflasche so eine kleine jetzt jetzt nicht so einen taucher keine
taucherflasche oder so also eine so druckluft reinigung oder so spray spray
dose ja oder den kompressor aber so was hier solche dinger so was ist so was
ist ganz praktisch
weil je nach gerät kann man einfach rein pusten als mit dem staubsauger
raussaugen und diese flaschen sind halt ganz praktisch
stöpselste vorne den stift rein so habe ich meinen schiel tv letzten zauber
gemacht das schiel tv hat die ganze zeit krach gemacht mit dem mit dem lüfter
schiel tv aufgemacht vier fünf mal reingepustet mit der druckluftflasche
zugemacht leise wie neu
really dirty just look at this fan filter i immediately wash these out off
camera everything else i just gave a good ja ok er macht sein gehäuse sauber
which isn't awful for my use case but cmr is really what you want for a server
application like this one if you don't know you can buy external drives many
was war das noch mal das ist ob sich die festplatten überlagern die ob sich die
magnet disks überlagern oder nicht gär smr und cmr das ist irgendwie ob die
platten irgendwie übereinander liegen und dann irgendwie rausgerechnet wird was
es wirklich ist und da habe ich mich nie so genau mit beschäftigt aber du kriegst
glaube ich auf die eine sache halt mehr storage drauf für den gleichen preis
mit ein paar tagen mit einem höheren preistag als ihre stand-alone counterpart
die große verwendung ist eine kurze gewährung aber es ist auf dich zu entscheiden
ob die cost savings ist worth es war mal vor ein paar jahren total im trend dass
die leute sich so was gekauft haben und dann die festplatten ausgebaut haben die
wurden geschackt oder wie nannte sich das schacking oder so geschuckt und
geschackt wurden die dann die ausgebaut ausgebautes wort ist zu
zu und cool
sternow drives and over the course of a month or so baut up six 14 terabyte wd
element drives an average cost of 215 dollars a piece or around 1300 dollars
total that's pretty good for 84 terabytes of raw capacity and once they were in it
was time to crack them open and see what i got opening these wd element drives is
actually pretty simple it takes some force but all you have to do is slide the
shots of the outer shell away from each other then with the little wiggling the
two halves will separate you pop out the drive and the for was jetzt gucken wie
man das ausspricht
wie spricht man okay erzählen wir spricht man das aus
schacking schacking habe ich doch richtig ausgesprochen
berz will just fall away as they're just pressure fit in then you can unscrew one
screw here and another here which will allow you to pull away the usb adapter
pcb and boom you have a freshly shucked there was die amis geritten hat ww zu
nennen verstehe ich bis heute nicht this is a lot quicker than opening the
seagate external drives and took like 10 minutes tops to do all of them i pulled
out with my number two epsilon is schon echt hängen geblieben aber wd 14 0e dgc
after a bit of research i believe these are white label versions of wds 14
terabyte red plus drives which is awesome as those go for $270 or more
meaning that me waiting for deals on external drives save me about $50 per
drive or 300 total which is a pretty significant savings in my opinion these
are 7200 rpm drives rated for nasus making them perfect for my storage
server also these are cmr drives which are suited much better for storage
servers like the one i'm building something to note is some wd drives
that have been shocked won't be recognized by your system to my six
drives did this but the fix is simple you can either like me use them for you
okay weiter weiter weiter mal ein bisschen vorspulen
in an odd connector design
was ist das für ein ding in but a normal one will slip right in the case
der cpu lüfter oder oder was war das pretty smoothly and the pc luckily booted
right up some random things to mention is that the fan headers on the motherboard
have an extra pin and an odd connector design but a normal one will slip right
in a place like this also when installing all the drives i could only use two
screws per sled as the holes just didn't line up to install more with that being
said they're pretty secure and i'm confident in their safety i just have
ssd hanging loose which is where they'll stay for now other random things used in
the building include some of these thin sata cables
das achter sind sata kabel ich dachte das ist eben ein sass sass zu sata wo was am
endefekt kann kommen pcs cruise i already had lying around i also temporarily
installed this gt 430 as a video out which will be used for the initial setup
of the server with the hardware side of things done i was ready to move on to
the software side of things for version 1.0 i used unread which was the best
option for that configuration with that being said now that i have cmr drives and
more ram i'm gonna go with what i wanted to use originally for version 1.0 which
is true nass unread is great for an archival based storage server but true
nass in general is better suited for a server being used more actively and it'll
give me the ability to do stuff like edit videos directly off of it and do tons
of true nass direkt ach so über den laubert install he das ist ein netzwerk
storage ob jetzt true nass das netzwerk storage macht oder ob das unread macht
ist doch vollkommen egal ich mein gut mit unread machst du keine
richtig echten klassischen rates mit true nass schon aber ich bin eh da
meinung na gut bei so vielen festplatten da
können dann rate 6 machen zum beispiel rate 6 würde sich anbieten
er hat sechs platten er nimmt vier platten für daten und zwei platten als
parity das könnte er machen dann hat er ziemlich schnelle read performance und
write performance ist auch gut aber die zugriffszeiten sind
halt naja
und so war der server related things like host game servers for my friends and
myself also unlike unread true nass ist free and open source i'm not at all an
expert in medievolt nee ich habe auch medievolt aber auch nie richtig benutzt
ich habe es immer ein paar mal ausprobiert aber so wirklich warm
geworden bin ich damit ich very much just scratching the surface of all this i
will briefly go over the setup process but for a detailed explanation i'll
link the crap computing tutorial create the bootable drive as i had and had to
redo this procedure and select boot from uefi so if you're building a server
with the same board make sure to select uefi ich sag immer efi ich sag noch nicht
mal uefi ich sag einfach immer efi ob das jetzt korrekt ist oder nicht ist mir
auch ziemlich egal i gave the pool a name in ja ok das kann man sparen
i have letter this is over a gigabit connection read and write speeds are
going to max out around 90 megabyte moment er hat auch nicht mal eine 10 g
karte drinne what the fuck second but i think i will install a 10 gigabyte
net das ist ja absolut verschenkt so viele pci expresse so viele pci express
und dann so viele platten als der kriegt der kriegt lock also also auf jeden fall
es ist definitiv zu langsam das ist over a gigabit connection read and write
speeds are going to max also 80 das ist das ist definitiv zu langsam selbst für
gigabit und der kriegt mit den vielen platten kriegt er locker das das vier
fünf fache megabytes per second but i think i will install a 10 gigabyte nick
in this machine that will connect directly to a 10 gigabyte nick in my pc
which will enable me to ich würde einfach ein 10 gig wird noch mit 10
gigabits wird schon die sind ja teilweise gar nicht mehr so teuer wenn
man den richtigen holt edit off of it directly if you want to see an update video
in the future where i add more ram upgrade the cpu add ssd cash and add 10
gigabit networking to the server then let me know in the comment section below
again the server is just housing files right now but with the ever have a high
core count immerhin ist er kein windows server auf dem ding u and 64 gigs of ram
means there's a ton naja ok alles klar dass das video hätten wir uns jetzt auch
sparen können ehrlich gesagt so was schauen wir uns als nächstes an
essential nee wir lassen uns level cap jibben nee nee ich will nicht wissen wie
john karmack sein wimp verwendet level cap wir lassen uns eine runde level cap
jibben auf geht's this week in gaming wenn das er uns wieder erzählt huge
change in battlefield 2042 und am ende fragt er uns und denkt er jetzt das
battlefield 2042 in einem besseren spot ist und ich weiß dass ich jedes mal das
gleich zu dem sagt was er sagt 42 season 2 was revealed playstation made some
pretty bad decisions amazon might buy ea and much more on this game amazon
kauft ea mal wisst ihr was ganz im ernst amazon kriegt mit games überhaupt
nichts auf die reihe also dass amazon mal einen spielehersteller kauft
beziehungsweise ups battlefield 2042 season 2 etwas was mehr rechte an
unterschiedlichen spieleherstellern hat das wäre vielleicht gar nicht so blöd
playstation made some pretty bad decisions amazon might buy ea and much
more on this week in gaming dice revealed battlefield 2042 second season
this week it'll go live on all platforms on august 30th season 2 offers
a bit more content than season 1 but players are concerned it still won't be
enough to keep them satisfied it introduces the new stranded map which
is a smaller space than the other 2042 maps season 2 also as a new
diese container maps man diese container maps warum die haben nur
container auf allen maps mittlerweile support specialist named crofford his
special gadget is a minigun emplacement that comes with a ballistic shield three
new weapons two new vehicles in a new concussion grenade are also shipping was
season 2 and despite the update not boasting a lot of content it does
appear to be in line with the community's expectations for quality and
design several weapons from 2042 portal mode are also being added into all-out
warfare dice refers to them as bald war ich meine wenn die sein solche maps
ins dem must be unlocked through a new assignment system the m60 for an m16 a3
from battlefield 3 are the first to go live but other portal weapons will
follow throughout the season as well the two new map reworks with renewal and
orbital this week's episode of inside stars also danach es kann sich doch
keiner bei da ist wirklich mal später woanders bewerben als level designer und
die fragen dann ja zeigt doch mal ein bisschen was was du gebaut hast und
da zeigt er in drei maps die aus container bestehen
die sind dann so leute die dürfen dann das fünfte shipment remake in für modern
warfare 25 bahn ok dass ich mich nicht die requested improvements that are in
the works firstly the devs are currently working on a massive
also nicht das revamp das interessiert mich investors and gamers were equally
surprised this week when rumors circulated that tech giant amazon was
planning to acquire electronic arts the report came from the swedish gaming
agency glhf they claimed that amazon was set to buy EA however just an hour
also ich glaube nicht dass wir das sehen dass mit microsoft und activision war
schon ein hammer weiß gar nicht ob das jetzt mittlerweile eigentlich mal durch
ist aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
released analysts from CNBC shot down the rumor stating that amazon had no plans
of acquiring EA it's long been rumored that the gaming giant would be bought by
somebody but who knows du kennst ein aber da ist arbeitet der durfte nur die
finger modellieren ist aber die bezahlen dem ganz schön viel geld dafür dass er
nur finger modelliert oder na gut in einem shooter ist die hand gar nicht so
unwichtig weil das das einzige ist was von einem charakter siehst was what the
future actually holds for this company sony announced that both models of its
playstation 5 console would receive a price increase worldwide in most regions
the price increases around $50 sony claims the price increases due to the
world's economic state and that the cost of production has forced them to raise
the price thankfully microsoft natürlich natürlich
komm sobald es möglich ist und die wissen dass die leute einen höheren
preis akzeptieren machen sie das er würde be changing the price of its
series consoles of making them an even better deal than before
despite this sony still holt nur mit dem unterschied dass es keine spiele für die
regions in better news sony did reveal their new controller the dual sense edge
features everything found on the base controller while offering many
customization features they include a remappable buttons stick sensitivity
tuning and faster input no release date or price has been shared yet in other
playstation news sony are being sued in the uk for allegedly overcharging
consumers for their games over the past six years is a group da hat er da hat er
bauer ein video zu gemacht das kann man uns angucken
juckt mich nicht
neue grafik an seo confirmed that they would finally share concrete details on
the new rtx 40 series graphics card at the gtc event in september during
invidias investor call this week where the company reported a 44 percent revenue
decline the ceo ended things on a high note by stating that the new gpus would
be revealed very soon enthusiast have speculated for months about what
performance reveals soon da hätte auch genauso wie nix sagen können
will offer and thankfully will know for sure in just a few weeks rumors online
suggest the next gen rtx cards will be very power hungry before we get to our
next year your thoughts on battlefield 2042 season 2 con
der macht immer das gleiche alter es war so klar dass er das fragen wird weg damit
reicht für heute genug genug level kept you bait
das war ihm zu langweilig und jetzt macht er augmented reality aha dann da
braucht man aber auch finger
so was gucken wir uns als nächstes an
omelette tools gott hier developer roadmap
das ist ein fire ship video
ok wir lassen uns von fire ship erklären wie wir ein gott hier developer werden
was wir hier machen werden wir werden wir werden wir werden wir werden wir werden
ok wir lassen uns von fire ship erklären wie wir ein gott hier developer werden was
haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten lohnt wir können uns auch vom bauer das
neue 240 herz ohne display angucken
das ist das ist kurz gesagt die haben teilweise auch titel in letzter zeit
alle warum ich hier anders heiße weil ich den account schon lange angelegt
habe bevor ich selbst üben wollte und dann dachte ich mir so weißt du was
nimmst einfach den account dann erkennens auch nicht so viele leute weil
es ist einfach so auf youtube haben wir schon einige deppen und alle dies hier
herfinden
und nicht anhand des namens die sind high IQ und passen hier gut rein
ok gott gott hier developer ok zeige ja die videos on youtube telling you the
number one programming language to learn right now if you want to be rich
that's not what we're doing today instead we're going to travel to the
deepest darkest depths of the software engineering field to discover the
programming languages that are loved hated beautiful ugly and compiled
interpreted useful weird wo ist meine lieblinge sprache
sekunde gut das c plus plus da unten ist das finde ich schon mal angebracht
rust c sharp c sharp ist auf wo
leicht unterhalb der meeresoberfläche ok also quasi layer 4 wenn er das sagt
beautiful ugly and compiled interpreted useful weird and everything in between
if you make it to the end you'll have a roadmap for everything you need to know
to land a job as a junior developer in 2023 ist das was battlefield 2042 benutzt
in portal or it might just make you extremely depressed because this iceberg
is just the tip of the iceberg of what you actually need to learn choose any
language and you'll find another iceberg with it's kein witz ich meine das
ernst guckt euch gleich mal ich hoffe da zeigt was ja da zeigt was
with any one of the languages we're about to look at before we get started
there's quite a few programming icebergs out there but this one ranks
languages based on where i think you might encounter them as a beginner
learning how to code from scratch each level has its own theme so er ist auch
ein iron sight enjoyer wie sie das schon mal gut zu it with languages that are
designed to make programming as easy as possible if you know absolutely nothing
about programming the best place to start in my opinion is scratch it was
developed at mit like some other languages on this list but instead of
typen ja guckt euch das an das ist der portal logik editor
fast fast 1 2 1
oh you drag and drop these blocks together
guckt
hat schon hat schon gewisse ähnlichkeiten
like lego bricks to represent we haben ja nachgeguckt portal ist glaube ich
block block lie block lie aber das geht alles in die gleiche richtung variables
control flow and operators it makes the thinking process behind programming much
more accessible and you might be surprised at what you can actually build
with it long before scratch that we had basic or beginners all-purpose symbolic
instruction to make it is actually difficult because you have to text to
mathematical things parsen most people do it in a calculator with buttons to
click or something like give them the first number give them the second number
and so on that is of course easy but the entry to mathematical things parsing is
difficult
but it wasn't beginner friendly basic provides a bunch of basic commands like
print go to and for and was included in most personal computers which made it
the go-to option for people learning to code for the next 50 years now moving
on to the next year we have the extremely popular dynamic high-level languages the
language most people start with today is python primarily because of its minimal
syntax it doesn't require curly braces semicolons and stuff like that and in
some cases it's a little bit more complicated but it's a little bit more
complex and stuff like that and instead uses indentation to represent different
blocks of code the other popular high-level language is javascript
syntactically it's pretty ugly but it's a requirement if you want to do web
development and almost every developer will have to touch it at some point in
their career in the application that has the right to say i also have a java
script comes to eigentlich nicht vorbei also an ein bisschen webentwicklung also
die die die der klassiker aus java script html css
kommst du nicht dran vorbei vielleicht als ibm mainframe kovol entwickler
java script now after learning one of these languages will be able to build
pretty much anything you can imagine and you could have an entire career as a
software engineer jetzt muss ich fragen kurke was sagst du was ist was ist die
welche programmier sprache ist gut wenn wenn python schmutz ist für dich es
kommt wahrscheinlich z plus plus oder irgendwie so was
Without going any further down the iceberg, but you don't want to be on your deathbed wondering if you should have tried out PHP on this next
Here we have languages that are extremely popular
But a little more specialized programmers like to get things done from the terminal and there are scripting languages like bash and powershell that allow you to interact with
your computer programmatically instead of
Ich muss ja sagen powershell
Powershell an sich finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht was microsoft da gebaut hat allerdings finde ich ist powershell eklig interaktiv zu nutzen
Irgendwelche automatisierung sachen in powershell zu skripten ist ok für interaktive sachen zsh oder bash
Attacly instead of typing out the same commands over and over again write a bash script to make it reproducible now if you get into web
Development you'll also need to learn html and css which when combined together
Arguably form a turing complete programming language
They're not used for programming in the traditional sense
But rather to define the structure and style of a website and if I were to say html is not a programming language
I would be immediately canceled by the tech community in addition most apps need a database and the most common language for working with
Databases is structured query language you can call it sql sql or squeal this turing complete also ich ich persönlich
Bin ja jemand der sql sagt
Wie hammer wie sieht es bei euch so aus sql sql
Also ich mag sql und dann auch wirklich die die deutsche aussprache sql
Genau sql
Although not used for regular programming, but rather to read and write data in a relational database now
Wobei wir ja wissen dass jason eigentlich gar nicht jason heißen soll sondern
jason
Also aber noch letztes in dem video gesehen dass der jason erfinder gemeint hat es müsste eigentlich
jason heißen
But there are many other dynamic languages that might be a better fit for certain projects like php made it easy to build server-side
Webapps in the 90s and it's still very popular today lua is easier
nur
Aller alle sprachen wo die erase bei eins anfangen sind wir äußerst suspekt like roblox and world of warcraft
Ruby ist das roblox den crap verwendet wundert mich nicht
Ein objekt orientiert language also commonly used to build webapps with the rails framework if you work in data science
Wir können across or which is ruby ist richtig ganz ehrlich ich bin immer noch ein großer ruby fan
Aber es gibt halt in letzter zeit kaum kunde mehr was in ruby zu machen geschweige denn webanwendung heute in rails zu machen
statistics and data viz or julia a more modern option also used for
Scientific computing the one thing all these languages have in common is a dynamic type system
however, as you build more complex software you may realize that you need a more rigid framework and one way to accomplish that is
With a static type system this here makes up the bulk of production
First up we have java which kind of revolutionized programming with the java virtual machine it compiles to you by code that runs on the jvm
And that allows developers to target any computer architecture from a single code base syntactically
It's an absolute dumpster fire for beginners and the entire video about why people hate java
But also die china chinesen die mögen java guckt mal die trendende
Guckt euch die die github trends aus china an das ist gefühlt fast alles java
was it types in your code can make it much easier to understand and refactor
Aber was bei denen los ist weiß ich nicht
Pretty much make the code right itself java is legendary, but it was followed up by microsoft with c-sharp
It's a ball in many ways this is a giga chats am start
it's used to build games with unity as well as web and desktop apps with the dotnet framework another well
Loved tool for microsoft is typescript it takes javascript and adds a type system on top of it making it much easier to work with
On large complex projects if you're building a mobile app today
You'll likely be working with kotlin for android swift for ios or dart with the flutter framework these languages are all statically typed
But they go about it in a more modern concise way with features like type inference that
wirklich wenn ich wirklich eine mobile app bauen würde
Würde ich mir angucken wie gut das mit avalonia 11 geht vielleicht ist das der alternative und ansonsten ganz ehrlich
ich würde irgendwelche
javascript sachen nehmen
ionic oder irgendwie sowas wenn ich wirklich eine java app bauen eine mobile app bauen müsste
gibt es eigentlich eine gescheite c-sharp ide für linux ja nicht nur für linux für mac windows und linux
genau rider richtig was der chat auch schon gesagt hat das ist auch das was ich immer in den streams verwende
ich habe mir bei ich habe mir budget prains
mal vor zwei drei jahren dieses old desktop products pack gekauft ich will alles genau
für persönliche nutzung
all products pack da bezahlste ach neue preis es wird teuer
da bezahlt bezahlt also ich habe es jetzt schon eine ganze weile bezahlt ich 150 euro im jahr für alles
jetzt aber
bezahlt ich 173 euro demnächst
naja
was willst du machen
jährlich mache ich da ist halt alles dabei da ist
was ist denn alles dabei
ja
dabei was ok lass mal kurz gucken was ist das überhaupt alles was da dabei ist also
rider
er
er plus plus ich habe keine ahnung was das ist
er er plus plus ich habe keine ahnung
go
ps
pp die pp webstorm
sea lion
keine ahnung data
dings grip
keine ahnung
pie charm
er
intelli-j ruby mein
der rest sagt mir auch nix
steht ja auch dabei wohl hätten wir vielleicht mal unten gucken sollen was es ist
nach app code
das ist irgendwelches ios solche go land
also was bei mir lohnt sich halt insofern ich verwende von den das da ich verwende von den das da und ich verwende von den das da
ab und zu ab und zu verwende ich das da
und ja die könnte ich nicht mehr der könnte ich eigentlich verwenden aber da bin ich bei visual studio code manchmal manchmal
also so irgendwie einmal die letzten fünf jahre ruby mein wenn es auch irgendwelche ruby sachen gibt
sind verstehen geblieben
ja
next up we have go which is a high performance language developed at google to build low-level systems it was designed blazingly fast written in go ganz wichtig in the readme
replacement for sea and ken thompson one of the original creators of sea helped design it the syntax is nice and concise making it approachable to beginners and it has a garbage collector which means unlike sea developers don't need to worry about manual memory
ich bin gar nicht so großer fan der go syntax wir haben jetzt ja auch ein paar sachen in go gemacht also
schön finde ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht this point we've reached the level of the iceberg where most people are afraid to go any deeper things are gonna get weird what happens is that many developers get jaded with these big heavy object oriented languages and go searching for a better way at this level we have functional languages the most which is haskell instead of classes inheritance and all kinds of crazy design patterns abstraction you really need is the function it was inspired by the miranda language and is named after the mathematician haskell
curry most importantly variables are immutable and functions have no side effects surprisingly you can build almost anything with these limitations although most production code out there is not functional most of us run into problems when trying to figure out what a monad is which in layman's terms is just a monoid in the category of n functors haskell
logisch obvios obvios der riesen vorteil von f-sharp ist das läuft auf der dotnet runtime das heißt du kannst easy interop machen zwischen c-sharp und f-sharp und jetzt haltet euch fest wishell basic dotnet
das ist diese lisp abklatsche oder? der eben der nur aus klammern besteht
wisst ihr was das problem ab diesem iceberg layer schon ist das mögen alles coole sprachen mit coole ideen sein die sich für manche sachen auch super eignen aber du findest keine leute die das können
versuch mal sowas versuch damit mal eben komplex ja dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen library auswahl sicherlich auch nicht so der wahnsinn bei den meisten aber versuch mal damit was zu programmieren in einem größeren team du findest ja gar keine leute die das verstehen
ich weige dir nicht das können das ist echter fachkräftemangel ja? C die chatlanguages leute
also rein vom ansatz her ist C tatsächlich also vom sprachumfang her nicht schwierig zu lernen das problem an C ist dass du auf sehr viele sachen achten musst und manches wirklich durch die brust ins auge ist also da werden sachen nach void pointers gecastet um sie dann
irgendwie als pointer rum zu reichen durch zig funktionen wo sie dann irgendwann wieder zurückgecastet werden also da den überblick zu behalten ist nicht so ohne auto gibt es in C moment es gibt in C auto ich dachte es ist in C++ Geschichte
oh
schlimmste was es gibt leute schlimmste was es gibt
der witz war gar nicht schlecht mit dem pointer und der und und monka gun meines pointer heißen logischerweise nicht so weil es so weil das so ist als schießt einer auf dich aber hat schon gewisse parallel software like game engines compilers and so on
die in C++ are still extremely relevant today but the modern chat tends to prefer rust for low level programming blazingly fast written in rust doesn't have a garbage collector but unlike C and C++ it uses a technique called borrow checking instead of pointers for memory management this makes it much easier to write memory safe programs and consistently ranks as the most loved language in the world the languages on this tier are extremely popular but now we descend further into the modern languages that use the most popular language in the world
okay ich habe keine ahnung was die hälfte davon ist nimm kenn ich das ist sick das haben wir letztens auch gesehen ich habe keine ahnung was das ist das ist wie lang ich weiß nicht wofür man es verwendet und von den anderen habe ich keine ahnung was es sein soll es wäre schon praktisch hören aber wenn man anhand des logos irgendwie erkennt was es sein soll
wir haben gehört auf der stelle wir haben gabon ist ja auch noch performance language das ist ja noch ganz neu but unlike go it doesn't use a garbage collector and unlike rust it doesn't do borrow checking but it can still create memory safe applications with its own auto free innovation where the compiler basically cleans everything up i have no idea how it works but it looks cool another modern for c is sick it's designed to simplify low-level programming by eliminating features like macros and metaprogramming es hat noch nie einer von sick war
gehört gibts zu ihr habt erst was von sick gehört als letztes diese java script runtime rausgekommen ist die in sick programmiert war niemand hat vorher was von sick gehört
ich glaube nicht dass sich carbon cross durchsetzen wird
was für mich?
kristel kristel kenne ich kristel das sind die die ruby nachbauen wollten die einen ruby compiler ursprünglich bauen wollten und dann eine eigene sprache draus gebaut haben
lisp ist für alle leute die klammern mögen
wie man hier sieht ich finde lisp-syntag so hässlich es gibt ja leute die schwören da drauf ich finde das so abartig
endlich wo sind die cobalt chats endlich mal eine ordentliche sprache
endlich ja wird auch mal zeit
leute ich habe mehr cobalt erfahrung ich sage jetzt mal wirklich die wahrheit ich habe mehr cobalt erfahrung als 99,99 prozent der weltbevölkerung wenn es reicht
was nicht heißt dass ich gut cobalt kann aber ich habe immerhin schon mal was kleines in cobalt gemacht
das war schon genug cobalt was wir gemacht haben
so geil leute wer es nicht glaubt archiv wir haben das bestimmt immer schief
cobalt da ist es
cobalt hier mit der passenden schriftart dazu
guckt euch das ehlend mal an leute
except keck we in from sus in
also wer es mir nicht glaubt massive cobalt erfahrung
ja man kann das wenigstens lesen
leute
Form, und dann so normales Teppichmesser. Teppichmesser kann man immer gebrauchen.
Für alles mögliche. Teppichmesser sind tatsächlich sehr praktisch.
Ganz so lang muss man es jetzt auch nicht zeigen.
Okay, da darf ich nichts zu sagen. Ich habe viel zu viel Geld ausgegeben für den Kram.
Ich habe mir sogar, also was ich mega nice finde, was ich aber keinem empfehlen würde zu kaufen.
Ich überlege gerade, wo habe ich es denn? Ich weiß nicht, wo ich es hingeschmissen habe gerade.
Wahrscheinlich ist es in der Werkzeughalter hinten. Ich habe mir ein Swiss Tool.
Swiss Tool, boah, wie heißt dieses Ding? Nein, nein, nein, nicht so ein Ding.
Gekauft mit wechselbarem.
Weiß nicht mal, wie das Ding hieß. Ja, so ein Teil, genau.
So was in der Richtung. Ne, Moment, länger, der da, so was da in der Richtung.
Ich hatte mir so ein Ding mal gekauft, das ist wirklich vom Handling her mega nice.
Kannst du nicht sagen, preislich komplett für einen Arsch.
Sollte man eigentlich nicht ausgeben. Ich meine, die wollen allen Ernstes für...
Es geht ja sogar noch. Die wollen, also das ist teilweise wirklich extrem teuer.
Aber ich fand es nice. Also vom Handling her ist es nice.
Die Ratsche ist wirklich super leichtläufig und fein, wie nennt man das so?
Feinfühlig oder so. Ja, ist mittlerweile, das ist wirklich mein Standardding mittlerweile,
wenn ich irgendwas zusammenbaue. Ich habe den Tisch für die, feinzahnig, genau.
Ich habe den Tisch für die Terrasse zusammengebaut, die Liege für die Terrasse zusammengebaut.
Wenn ich sonst irgendwas aufmachen muss, wird das damit gemacht.
Also ich nehme eigentlich, wenn irgendwo was ist, wo ich mal gucken muss oder irgendwas basteln muss,
ich nehme eigentlich nichts mit, außer dieses Ding. Zu 90% kommt man damit klar.
Sehr praktisch, aber unsinnig teuer. Ich habe mich dadurch durch ein Review-Video
auf YouTube zu inspirieren lassen und ja, war eigentlich reichlich sinnlos, aber ok. Ok,
was haben wir sonst noch? Ein Dremel. Ja, so ein Teil habe ich auch. Das ist wirklich sehr praktisch,
wenn man es braucht. Ich brauche selten, aber es ist praktisch. Zum Beispiel musste ich mal,
ihr werdet euch jetzt sicherlich fragen, wozu, aber werde ich euch dann erzählen. Wäscheständer.
Ich musste mal Wäscheständer durchschneiden. Ich musste mal Metallstangen von Wäscheständer
durchschneiden. Und da war ich wirklich froh, dass ich diesen Dremel hatte,
mit den passenden Scheiben dran. Und normalerweise ist das nicht das,
was ich oft machen muss. Und mir ist aufgefallen, dass es tatsächlich Funken gibt, wenn man
Metall mit Metall durchschneidet. Ihr werdet jetzt sagen, Max, das weiß man doch. Das war mir zu
dem Zeitpunkt aber nicht ganz klar, dass es Funken gibt, wenn man mit Metall mit Metall durchschneidet.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum man bei sowas normalerweise besser eine Schutzbrille aufzieht.
Ja, für solche Sachen enorm praktisch. Ich habe damit auch schon kleine Sachen geklettet,
jetzt habe ich das Wort, also mit so einem Schleifzeug oder poliert oder durchgeschnitten
oder durchgesägt. Also für so kleine Sachen ist das Ding universell wirklich äußerst praktisch.
Man kann damit theoretisch auch bohren und schrauben, was man aber nicht machen will,
dafür ist es nicht da. Ja, aber gerade so Sachen, wenn man mal so was braucht. Ich meine,
wie oft willst du Metallstäbe durchschneiden von einem Wäscheständer? Eigentlich nie. Und gerade
für so Sachen, die du eigentlich nie machst, aber doch ab und zu man machen muss, ist so ein
Universal-Tool praktisch, weil damit kannst du vieles machen, unter anderem halt mit dem
passenden Aufsatz Wäscheständer durchschneiden. Es ist übrigens genau der gleiche, den ich auch
habe. Ja, kannst du abschleifen. Gehst du heute Abend aufs Museumsuferfest? Ich war am Freitag
schon am Museumsuferfest und habe mir gedacht, meine Güte, was hier am Wochenende los ist,
da lasse ich mich bestimmt nicht blicken. Was hat er ab? Was hat er? Der hat das hier abgesägt oder
was? Ja, für so kleine Sachen sind die Dinger wirklich praktisch. Also das ist ein super
Universal-Tool für Sachen, die man normalerweise eigentlich nicht braucht, aber man doch mal machen
muss. Und du kannst halt alle möglichen Aufsätze drauf machen, deswegen sind die echt praktisch.
Also ich bin froh, dass ich mir auch so ein, es ist genau der gleiche aber auch den 3000er,
weil es der kleinste ist. Wirklich bin ich froh, dass ich mir das damals gekauft habe. Lass mich raten,
der hat so eine Infrarot-Wärme-Dings-Erkennungsteil jetzt. Ich habe mir das auch schon überlegt. Ich
finde die Dinger cool. Also cool ist vielleicht für was zum Wärme, das hat was. Aber ich habe
mir da mal angeguckt, was gute Geräte dafür kosten und dann dachte ich mir,
ne, so sehr will ich sowas auch nicht haben. Ich habe damals dann nach Dingern geguckt,
die so eine Wärmebildkamera noch drauf hatten, wo man das was sieht. Die waren nicht günstig,
die waren von gutem Herd, also diese Dinger, aber das war sicher geguckt, das hat was,
was ich, das ging irgendwie am 400 Euro los und da habe ich mir gedacht, ne. Alter Fahrenheit,
geht das auch in ordentlichen Einheiten. Nein, ich will das auch nicht in Kelvin, ich will das
in Celsius, weil ich damit besser was anfangen kann. Ich meine ganz im Ernst, warum haben die
Dinger kein Button, da kann man einfach durchtappen. Celsius, Kelvin, Fahrenheit, ist doch gut. Ich meine,
ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das umrechnend wahnsinnig kompliziert. Ja, praktisch. Ja,
ist praktisch, aber ganz im Ernst, wisst ihr was wirklich praktisch ist? Ich verwende,
ich hatte früher auch ein paar dieser Lampen, die du dir auf den Kopf setzen kannst. Borscht,
was weiß ich, Licht, weiß gar nicht, was ich da suchen muss. 12 Volt Licht oder ne. Das Teil,
echt praktisch, passen die gleichen Akkus wie von den Akkuschraubern in anderen 12 Volt Geräten
rein. Du kannst es irgendwo hinhängen und es macht halt einfach hell. Es macht nicht so auf
einen Punkt hell wie ne Taschenlampe oder ne Kopflicht, es macht aber halt einfach die
gesamte Raumhälfte hell, wo du was gucken musst. Seitdem ich das Ding hab, benutze ich eigentlich
im Keller oder sonst wo oder im Stall oder in der Garage immer, wenn ich irgendwie da mal was
gucken mach, ich benutze nur noch das. Hinstellen, du kannst es hinstellen, du kannst es, du kannst
es hinlegen, du kannst es irgendwo dran machen. Magnetisch ist es, glaube ich, ist eine gute
Frage. Ich glaube, magnetisch ist es nicht. Ne, ich glaube magnetisch ist es nicht. Weiß ich
gar nicht. Ich glaube es ist nicht magnetisch. Also zum Beispiel im Keller hänge ich das an die
Decke, an irgendein Kabel und ich sehe alles. Wunderbar. Also ich benutze keine Kopflichter
mehr, ich benutze keine Taschenlampen mehr seitdem ich das Ding hab. Zumal es mit dem
gleichen 12 Volt Akku für die Akkuschrauber und dem Bohrer, ne nicht, der kann bohren,
was immer der Akkuschrauber geht. Äußerst praktische Sache. Rühr dich auch viele solcher
Kopflichter. Ja, du könnt, da hast du die Hand frei, aber bei dem anderen hast du auch
die Hand frei, weil das einfach hinten neben dich stellen kann. Random Frage, hattest du
zu letzter Zeit nochmal in WW3 reingeschrott? Nein. Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was mit den
Map-Designern dort los war, warum die allen Ernstes in Berlin das Arbeitsamt auf eine
Map gepackt haben, aber ok. Passt mal auf hier. Wir hatten ja wirklich. Hallo Leute, hier ist
der Max. Agentur für Arbeit. Sind die durch Berlin gelaufen und haben einfach mal Fotos
gemacht von allen möglichen Dingern die da rumhängen oder was? Warum ist das Arbeitsamt
auf der Map drauf? Wer kennt es nicht, die Schlacht am Arbeitsamt? Wahrscheinlich wussten
die einfach gar nicht, was sie da fotografiert haben. Machst du am Dienstag einen Battlefield
2042 Stream? Kann durchaus sein. Neue Season gucken wir uns an. Ist doch realistisch. Ich
weiß halt nicht, ob die beste Ecke in Berlin ist das für eine Map, wo das Arbeitsamt ist.
Velcro. Ja, da hat er recht. Die Amis nennen das ja immer Velcro, wahrscheinlich weil der
Hersteller da super bekannt ist. Die sagen ja auch Xerox für Kopieren und solche Sachen.
So wie wir Tempo sagen für Taschentücher oder Nutella oder was es da sonst nicht noch
alles gibt. Die Dinger sind wirklich praktisch. Also Klettverschlüsse bzw. diese Hybriddinger
aus Seite, die klebt und Klettverschluss, die sind tatsächlich echt praktisch. Klettband,
ja. Also ich mag bei diesen Dingern zum befestigen von Geräten. Es gibt welche, die haben auf
der einen Seite Kleber und auf der anderen Seite haben die Klettbandseite. Also auf der
einen Seite kannst du es dran kleben, auf der anderen Seite hast du eine Halterung für
so einen Klettverschluss. Dann machst du das an das Gerät auf der einen Seite und beispielsweise
an den Kühlschrank machst du die andere Seite und dann kannst du die Dinger miteinander
verbinden. Quasi musst du sie nicht aufeinander kleben, sondern kannst sie einander kletten.
Ja gut, Kabelbinder haben wir glaube ich alle da. Rack, Mounting, Muttern und Schrauben.
Ja, braucht man. Was soll immer das sein sein? Irgendwelche Abstandshalter. Was zum? Ich
erkenne nichts. Alter, ich sehe nichts. Was? Ja, braucht keiner. Also wenn das die China-Chinesen-Kram
ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Na gut, okay, war jetzt nicht so viel Spannendes dabei.
Kegweight. Wir wurden betrogen. Da hat ich aufgepasst. Der Auer zeigt uns ein flexibles
45 Zoll OLED Display mit 240 Hertz. Ja, coole Technik, aber bestimmt am Ende so unglaublich
teuer, dass selbst ich mir diesen Kreppel nicht kaufen würde. Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Ich bin dreieinhalb Stunden on. Ich bin geneigt dazu jetzt oft zu gehen und was zu futtern.
Ja, ich hoffe ihr seid wach. Ja, es gibt andere die streamen jeden Tag sieben Stunden
ohne Probleme. Ich weiß, aber ich bin ja auch schon Boomer. Ich weiß nicht wie der Lost
das teilweise sieben Stunden am Stück durchhält oder andere Streamer. Keine Ahnung. Sogar
den Krieger habe ich teilweise zehn Stunden plus herum hocken sehen. Wie macht ihr das
denn so lang? Na gut, man muss sagen, ich glaube viele Streamer, die schwätzen auch
nicht so viel wie ich, oder die spielen irgendwas, geben da Kommentare zu. Aber ich bin ja quasi
dreieinhalb Stunden. Ich hole ja quasi nie Luft. Ich laber ja, ich glaube, ich laber
ja eigentlich dreieinhalb Stunden durch. Michael fünf Spiljaren auch mal wieder am Start. Massive
Subscription. Da ist er. Dankeschön, 25 Monate. Henryus, Dankeschön für den Sub. Ja, und
die machen das Vollzeit. Natürlich, die müssen das machen, aber trotzdem. Deswegen wird es
ja nicht weniger anstrengend. Ich frage mich halt immer nur, wie die Leute das durchhalten.
Wenn ich das, wenn ich, ich würde das auch machen, denn ich, also nicht Vollzeit, aber
ich, für mich sind dreieinhalb Stunden schon anstrengend genug. Ich hätte gar keinen
Bock sieben Stunden zu streamen. Echt cooler Stream und inhaltlich sehr interessant. Ja,
schön, dass dir es gefallen hat. Wir haben uns ja heute eigentlich hauptsächlich mit
fremden Federn geschmückt und uns Videos angeguckt von anderen Leuten. Aber ansonsten, wir können
nicht immer High IQ Content selbst produzieren. So, schauen wir mal. 30 Milliarden, Dankeschön
für die Bits. Massive. Pog. Hast du dir mal Teleport angeschaut? Nein. Gut, dann werde
ich jetzt abhauen. 69% Leute. 69% für den Halbtrain. Ich wollte aber gerade aufgehen.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen. Schön, dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid. Wir sehen uns im
nächsten Stream. Wir müssen echt auch mal unseren Rust Ausflug weitermachen. Und spätestens,
wenn ich mein Auto habe und die Wallbox und so, müssen wir da auf jeden Fall einiges
basteln. Alles klar, bis denn. Macht's gut, CEO.